bien écoutez je vous propose que nous
commencions et j'aimerais avant d'entrer
dans le vif du sujet qui nous réunit ce
soir vous dire que nous avons évidemment
une pensée particulièrement émue pour
les deux soldats morts en mission au
mali
à la suite de l'explosion d'une mine
artisanale dans le cadre de l'opération
barkan voilà donc mesdames et messieurs
les membres de la presse
nous sommes ensemble cet après midi pour
parler de la loi du projet de loi du
gouvernement
dénommé asile et l'immigration dont je
vais vous dire quelques mots au nom des
sénateurs et des députés qui sont
présents et que je remercie pour leur
présence qui sont de bons connaisseurs
du sujet qui ont travaillé aux
contre-propositions que nous allons vous
vous présentez alors sur le texte du
gouvernement il s'agit essentiellement
d'un texte d'ajustements techniques avec
pour principal hobby ambition de faire
un peu mieux fonctionner les dispositifs
existants et si nous pouvons soutenir
certains aménagements techniques qui
sont prévus pour accélérer le traitement
des demandes d'asile
de notre point de vue le texte devrait
aller beaucoup plus loin la principale
préoccupation qui est la nôtre c'est de
mettre fin au détournement du droit
d'asile qui est devenu une voix majeure
de l'immigration clandestine
les déboutés du droit d'asile n'étant
pas reconduits dans leur pays ils
restent sur le territoire et deviennent
dès lors des clandestins je suis
d'ailleurs frappé plusieurs questions
ont été posées au ministre de
l'intérieur cet après midi aux questions
au gouvernement
il n'a jamais été question dans ses
réponses de reconduite
donc c'est assez symptomatique donc
l'absence de verrouillage à l'entrée et
la durée excessive de l'instruction ont
donné le sentiment que tout étranger
peut entrer en france sans être
inquiétés y être logés aux frais de
l'état et du contribuable pendant toute
la durée de la procédure
j'ajoute que la france est l'un des pays
les plus accueillants du monde ce n'est
pas nous qui le disons c'est la banque
mondiale la france est le troisième pays
de l'est cpe en nombre de réfugiés
résidant sur son territoire en 2005 16
derrière l'allemagne et la turquie
cela démontre bien qu'il n'ya pas besoin
d'assouplir encore le droit d'asile
comme le font certaines dispositions du
texte notamment l'élargissement du
regroupement familial nous y reviendrons
il faut au contraire posé un regard
lucide sur la situation de notre pays
près de 500 mille migrants sont entrés
irrégulièrement dans l'espace schengen
en 2016 après le record historique d'un
million huit dents très irrégulière en
2015 d'après font entre frontex un
nombre important de ces migrants demande
par la suite l'asile alors que pour
certains ils viennent de pays sûrs en
2017 le nombre de demandeurs d'asile a
atteint un niveau record avec 100 milles
plus de cent mille demandes déposées
soit une augmentation de 17 % en un an
le nombre de demandeurs d'asile a
d'ailleurs doublé en dix ans 64 % des
demandes d'asile ont été rejetées en
2017 et derrière on sait que très peu de
débouter sont expulsés j'irai même que
là est le coeur du problème et ça
rejoint ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure c'est vraiment l'angle mort du
discours du gouvernement notamment dans
le cadre des questions au gouvernement
la cour des comptes avait estimé en 2015
que seulement 4% des déboutés était
expulsé les parlementaires les
républicains seront pleinement impliqués
dans les débats parlementaires
vers notamment le travail d'amendements
du texte alors aujourd'hui nous avons
voulu conjointement présenté des contre
propositions communes au groupe l'est
républicain de l'assemblée nationale et
du sénat
et évidemment avec le les services du
parti les républicains ces propositions
s'articulent autour de trois principes
qui guideront notre position lors de
l'examen du texte
premier principe pas de nouvel appel
d'air en direction des migrants
l'absence de maîtrise quantitative du
phénomène migratoire ne nous permet plus
d'intégrer correctement les nouvelles
personnes qui arrivent en outre elle
pèse il faut le dire sur notre système
de protection sociale et sur les
finances publiques
à titre d'exemple lors du dernier projet
de loi de finances
eh bien nous avons du gouvernement a dû
rajouter près de 100 millions au
financement de l'aisne les propositions
du rapport d'aurélien attaché reprises
dans le texte sont particulièrement
préoccupantes de ce point de vue puisque
la demande d'ouverture du marché du
travail aux migrants dont les dossiers
sont en cours d'instruction au bout de
six mois voire plus tôt va inciter
évidemment encore plus de migrants
économiques a déposé une demande d'asile
infondée mais qui leur permettra de
commencer à travailler
et s'il ya rejet de leur demande de
demander une régularisation au titre du
travail
par ailleurs on peut s'interroger sur
l'équilibré d'un rapport sur
l'intégration qui compte près de 150
fois le mode roi pour seulement trois
fois mes mots de juin le deuxième
principe qui guide notre réflexion et
que la france doit pouvoir expulser les
déboutés du droit d'asile
et les clandestins derrière les
déclarations d'intention nous regardons
les faits le budget de la lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière est en baisse
de 7% pour 2018 nous l'avions d'ailleurs
signalé et dénoncé au moment de l'examen
du vote du budget pourtant aujourd'hui
la priorité devrait être donnée à
l'expulsion 92000 mesure d'éloignement
ont été prononcées en 2016 ciel 24000
ont été exécutés autour de 27%
les comparaisons avec l'allemagne et le
royaume uni ne sont pas à l'avantagé de
la france
si l'on se réfère au rapport
d'information présenté le 15 février par
notre collègue guillaume larrivé en
allemagne soixante quinze mille
ressortissants de pays tiers ont
effectivement quitté le territoire à la
suite d'une décision administrative ou
judiciaire
au royaume uni ce sont 47 mille
personnes contre 24 mille en france je
le rappelle donc nous allons vous
présenter des propositions précises qui
doivent permettre de faciliter
l'expulsion des migrants illégaux
j'ajoute et c'est un point sur lequel du
reste on peut partager le constat du
ministre de l'intérieur il l'a dit cet
après-midi les pays qui nous entourent
vont durcir la réglementation il est
bien évident que dès lors si nous
n'adaptons pas à nous réglementation à
ceux des autres pays qui nous entourent
il est bien évident que cela augmentera
les fait appel d'air enfin le troisième
principe qui va guider notre réflexion
et nos propositions
c'est que la france doit pouvoir choisir
qui est l'accueil sur son territoire on
l'a déjà dit je le répète il n'est pas
normal que ce soient des passeurs
particulièrement expérimentés et
particulièrement expérimentés qu'ils
soient habile à déjouer
évidemment nos systèmes de protection
qui décident de fait qui vient sur notre
territoire
c'est un gros point faible du texte
présenté par le gouvernement qui ne pose
pas la question de la maîtrise des flux
migratoires
le texte se concentre sur les îles or
l'immigration humanitaire qui comprend
l'asile ne représente que 15% des
premiers titres délivrés en 2010 est
donc le nombre de premiers titres
délivrés a atteint un niveau inédit
depuis 74 avec 260 2000 ou titres
délivrés en 2017 soit une augmentation
de 41% par rapport à la moyenne du
quinquennat sarkozy
les républicains auront donc l'occasion
dans les prochains mois de présenter une
remise à plat de l'ensemble de la
politique migratoire française
aujourd'hui nous nous concentrons sur le
texte présenté par le gouvernement et
sur ce point nous estimons que la france
doit au moins être en mesure de ne pas
faire entrer sur le territoire national
ou de garder sur le territoire des
immigrés délinquants
voilà donc les principes qui vont régir
notre notre réflexion et qui ont régi
les propositions qui vont vous être à
présent
présenté par bienvenu du blé muller et
roger karoutchi
mais d'ores et déjà je voudrais
remercier évidemment tous les collègues
qui ont accepté de travailler avec nous
donc une petite partie est là
aujourd'hui
jean louis masson car henri dumont donc
roger karoutchi et bien sûr eric ciotti
je vous remercie monsieur très
sincèrement de votre présence
aujourd'hui et ce sont eux qui
répondront mesdames et messieurs les
journalistes à vos questions je vous
remercie
donc merci annie pourre pour cette
présentation comme annie vous l'a
précisé
donc le groupe de travail qui s'est
composé de députés et sénateurs mais
aussi d'élus locaux a formulé un certain
nombre de propositions qui seront portés
par nos groupes parlementaires donc je
représente aujourd'hui christian jacob
vous savez qu'il est actuellement en
déplacement en nouvelle-calédonie dans
le cadre d'une mission parlementaire et
roger karoutchi s'exprimera bien sûr
pour le groupe
lr au sénat donc nos propositions
s'articulent autour de cinq thématiques
la première est donc le refus de
l'extension de la réunification
familiale ouverte aux frères et soeurs
des réfugiés mineurs
au delà donc des ascendants directs
puisque rien donc dans ce projet
n'indique une volonté de limiter les
flux migratoires comme c'était le cas
sous le quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy
par exemple certaines dispositions
relatives à l'asile élargissent au
contraire le champ des possibilités
c'est le cas notamment de l'article 3 du
chapitre 1 qui prévoit l'octroi dé
titres de séjour non seulement aux
parents mais aussi aux frères et soeurs
des mineurs réfugiés les républicains
vous le savez sont opposés à tout
élargissement du champ des possibilités
de l'immigration humanitaire ou
familiale alors que le nombre de
demandeurs d'asile a doublé en dix ans
et atteint un niveau sans précédent
puis 200 milles en 2017 il est selon
nous des raisonnable de prendre des
mesures susceptibles d'en augmenter
encore le nombre
bonjour d'abord nous aurons nous au
sénat une responsabilité un peu
particulière parce que naturellement
nous sommes majoritaires ce qui veut
dire que le texte qui sera débattu en
hémicycle qui sera votée par la majorité
sénatoriale ça le nôtre et non pas celui
du gouvernement
nous considérons comme le groupe de
l'assemblée que ce texte est
incantatoire n'apporte rien à part des
mesures prétendu si on y met les moyens
de raccourcissement des délais notamment
sur les recours
mais dans la réalité des faits ça ne
change pas la politique du droit d'asile
ça ne change pas la définition des pays
sûrs ça ne change pas du tout la
définition de la politique migratoire
que notre pays est supposé permettre la
situation est simple par tous les
centres de rétention sont plus que
débordés les migrants clandestins où
l'on occupe très largement les centres
d'hébergement d'urgence qui sont
normalement destinés à ceux qui parmi
des citoyens français sont des sdf ou
sont en situation difficile et donc nous
sommes globalement dans une situation
extraordinairement difficile par rapport
à l'immigration droit des îles virginie
vient de le dire
et avant elle est ni plus de cent mille
demandeurs d'asile l'année dernière
34% accepter ça nous pose un vrai sujet
et notre proposition est extrêmement
simple c'est que tous ceux qui sont
officiellement jeudi officiellement
parce que la réalité n'est pas là
demandeurs d'asile issus de pays qui ne
sont pas des pays en guerre qui ne sont
pas des pays acp de la dictature avec
une opposition muselée ou harcelés et
qui donc logiquement sont des gens qui
viennent plutôt en migration en
immigration économique et non pas en
demandeurs d'asile
je pense par exemple au cas des albanais
qui en 2017 ont été la première nation
pour les demandes d'asile 7600 seulement
six et demi pour cent ayant accepté par
l'ofpra la semaine des as
ce qui veut dire que très clairement les
albanais qui viennent de vendée sont des
immigrants et ne sont pas des demandeurs
d'asile nous demandons à ce que c'est
demandeurs d'asile faux demandeurs
d'asile entre guillemets venus de pays
sur soi mis immédiatement centre de
rétention administrative que l'ofpra qui
a procédure accélérée en quinze jours
qui peut d'ailleurs l'être en quatre
jours examine leur cas et que
naturellement si les demandes d'asile
sont refusés dans ces cas là est bien le
système de l'expulsion de
raccompagnement frontière soit immédiat
si on ne le fait pas ça veut dire qu'on
laisse ces gens qui ne sont pas de réels
demandeurs d'asile venir dans le pays
être disséminées on les retrouve pas
forcément ils n'ont pas le droit d'asile
et pour autant les raccompagne pas aux
frontières donc soyons au moins par
rapport à nous mêmes des défenseurs du
droit d'asile pour ceux qui réellement
en ont besoin et non pas pour ceux qui
le détourne la deuxième proposition que
nous formulons la troisième donc
concerne la création d'un nouveau
critère conditionnant l'aide au
développement de la france aux pays
étrangers puisque la délivrance des
laissez passer consulaires ne se fait
pas forcément dans les délais utiles
vous le savez les pays d'origine des
livres pas suffisamment de laisser
passer consulaire qui est un document
pourtant indispensable aux procédures
d'éloignement même si l'on constate que
des progrès ont été réalisés depuis 2013
moins de la moitié des laissez passer
consulaires demandée par la france
près de 46 2% ont été délivrés dans des
délais utiles à l'éloignement en 2016
les résultats obtenus sont donc très
hétérogène d'un pays à l'autre et seuls
11 8% des laissez passer consulaires par
exemple ont été délivré à temps pour le
parent le mali 17,2 pour le cas de
l'égypte et 48% pour l'algérie je tiens
à faire référence également aux rapports
d'information qui a été présenté par
notre collègue guillaume larrivé
qui indique également qu' aucun vol
groupé n'a été organisée en 2017 vers
les états d'afrique du nord ou de
l'ouest ni vers les pays du sahel
ce rapport note pourtant que de tels
vols groupés serait particulièrement
nécessaire il cite le sénégal le mali et
la guinée comme les trois pays d' qui
nous préoccupe principalement ceux ci
oppose d'ailleurs une très forte
résistance à la fois donc sur la
délivrance des laissez passer mais
également sur l'organisation de ces vols
groupés en cas d'échec de ces
négociations avec les pays d'origine la
france selon nous doit être en mesure de
prendre des mesures de rétorsion
systématique contre ces états
récalcitrants selon un principe s'il n'y
a pas de visa et bien il n'y aura pas
d'aidé au développement sans retour des
clandestins ça nous paraît être une
mesure est un principe de réciprocité
des mesures 4 et 5 concerne ce qu'ils
soient sont en situation irrégulière
soit sont des délinquants reconnu la
mesure 4 la quatrième mesure donc
concerne ceux qui sont en situation
régulière
déboutés du droit d'asile ou en
situation irrégulière s'ils sont des
immigrés économiques dans les deux cas
aujourd'hui
la règle n'est pas le centre de
rétention administrative ce qui veut
dire que pour le moment la règle c'est
vous restez dans le pays
en attendant l'expulsion ou leur
accompagnement aux frontières ce qui
veut dire que ça participe si je puis
dire au fait de ne pas les raccompagner
au delà de ce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure
à savoir que les crédits de
raccompagnement aux frontières ont
baissé en 2010 8 par rapport à 2010 est
si évidemment vous n'avez pas
physiquement
la personne a raccompagné sous la main
si je puis dire des autorités de police
naturellement on a beaucoup de mal à les
retrouver et à les accompagner aux
frontières donc l'idée c'est plutôt de
dire généralisation du centre de
rétention administrative pour ceux qui
sont déboutés du droit d'asile ou qu'ils
sont
en situation irrégulière généralisation
ça veut dire comme l'avait d'ailleurs
souligné eric ciotti que naturellement
les budgets aujourd'hui le nombre de
places dans les centres de rétention
sont très insuffisants il faut bien
entendu construire de nouveaux centres
de rétention c'est assez ridicule dans
un pays comme le nôtre où nous savons
que nous avons au minimum 400 mille
immigrés en situation irrégulière et au
minimum 65 mille déboutés du droit
d'asile chaque année d'avoir des centres
de rétention qui tout compris arrivé aux
alentours de 2000 ou 2500 places
on sait bien que ça ne correspond pas à
la réalité de la situation il faut donc
faire là dessus un effort comme l'a
rappelé dans qu'eric pour justement
qu'on ait une capacité d'accueil dans
les centres de rétention ça c'est pour
ceux qui sont en situation irrégulière
et qui doivent être accompagnés aux
frontières et puis la cinquième
proposition c'est naturellement mettre
un terme comme l'a d'ailleurs demandé le
président de la république mais qui ne
se fait toujours pas à savoir que tout
ce qu'ils demandent à entrer dans le
pays que ce soit sous le droit d'asile
ou ce soit d'ailleurs en situation
d'immigration et qui ont commis des
actes de délinquance dans leur pays
d'origine par exemple ne soient pas
accueillis et en sens inverse
que tous ceux qui sont ou qui commettent
des actes de délinquance en france soit
automatiquement expulsèrent accompagné
aux frontières après un passage en
centre de rétention administrative donc
là les choses sont simples
franchement pourquoi accepterait ton
dans notre pays que des demandeurs
d'asile ou déboutés du droit d'asile en
situation de délinquance reste dans le
pays il ya aucune raison il faut
naturellement les raccompagneront terre
je dis tout de suite que nous sommes
tous irini any two two two les débuts d
eric tout le monde au l air est
parfaitement sur une ligne simple le
droit d'asile est un droit fondamental
reconnu par la france depuis la
révolution française et nous sommes
extrêmement attentifs à ce droit d'asile
mais les détournements du droit d'asile
la saturation du droit d'asile par des
gens qui ne méritent pas l'asile pose un
vrai problème pour ceux qui en ont
réellement besoin
donc si on veut réellement répondre à
ceux qui sont en situation de guerre à
ceux qui sont en situation de torture ou
à ceux qui sont en situation de
harcèlement dans leur pays
il faut que naturellement on respecte
les règles et que le droit d'asile
soient défendues ce sont ces principes
de micro est branché oui c'est bon alors
on accueille constance le grip députés
les républicains qui a également
travaillé sur ces sujets qu'on invite à
nous rejoindre sur scène merci virginie
et merci à roger pour la présentation
des cinq mesures dont je rappelle
qu'elles sont bien
une réponse aux textes de loi qui va
être étudiée sous peu par nos assemblées
respectifs respectives mais que ce n'est
qu'une préfiguration du projet complet
que nous proposerons dans quelques temps
voilà mesdames et messieurs la parole
est à vous
oui quelques mots pour dire que
naturellement en l'état nous ne pouvons
pas soutenir ce texte
c'est un texte qui n'apporte aucune
réponse pragmatique efficace concrète à
la problématique et aux défis de
l'immigration
nous avons atteint en 2010 est des
records en matière d'immigration de
façon globale de 162000 titres de séjour
ont été octroyés nous avons atteint des
records en matière de demande d'asile
plus de 100000 première demande d'asile
en 2017 et tout à l'heure de façon assez
paradoxale
le ministre de l'intérieur soulignait
que les flux d'entrée de migrants en
europe s'était réduit par rapport à 2015
un million et demi par rapport à 2016
cinq cent mille en 2017 et il soulignait
qu'en revanche le nombre de demandes
d'asile avaient considérablement
augmenté en france
ignorant sans doute qu'il était lui même
en charge de l'inefficacité des
politiques et qui avait conduit à ces
records donc nous ne trouvons aucune
disposition dans ce texte
hormis des mesures techniques que nous
pouvons approuver
je pense notamment à l'augmentation de
la durée de retenue à l'augmentation à
la réduction de la durée d'appel ou à
l'augmentation à la réduction pardon du
délai pour déposer la demande d'asile de
120 à 90 à dix jours de l'augmentation
du délai de rétention
ce sont des mesures qui techniquement
vont dans le bon sens mais globalement
la politique qui est inspiré par ce
texte qui exprime ce texte ne répond je
le redis en rien à l'ampleur et à la
gravité des défis migratoires
au contraire ce texte je crois va
accroître nos flux migratoires d'abord
avec une mesure extraordinairement
dangereuse c'est l'extension du
regroupement familial pour les mineurs
réfugiés
et tous les collatéraux cette
possibilité était offerte aujourd'hui à
leurs ascendants elle va être désormais
possible pour les collatéraux dans le
texte ça veut dire que c'est un nouvel
appel d'air on voit bien l'enjeu qui va
être derrière la river deux mineurs
souvent isolés fruits de l'exploitation
de filières de passeurs
il va y avoir derrière une des filières
qui vont commercialiser l'arrivée de
toute une famille d'un mineur réfugiés
deuxième mesure extraordinairement
dangereuse c'est l'augmentation du la
possibilité la facilitation en tout cas
de pouvoir travailler pour les
demandeurs d'asile
cent mille demandeurs d'asile l'année
dernière aujourd'hui la faculté de
pouvoir travailler sera offerte aux
demandeurs d'asile qui ont effectué leur
demande depuis plus de six mois c'est à
dire la quasi totalité des demandeurs
d'asile ça veut dire que va arriver sur
le marché des travaux du travail
français plusieurs dizaines de milliers
de personnes supplémentaires renforçant
l'attractivité de notre pays quand
gérard collomb souligne l'aggravation de
ces chiffres par rapport à nos autres
partenaires européens il souligne que le
modèle français plus attractif et bien
les mesures qui sont dans ce texte vont
contribuer à en faciliter l'attractivité
et ensuite on ne retrouve aucune volonté
concrète de faciliter les éloignements
aujourd'hui si on veut protéger ce
principe fondamental comme le rappelait
roger karoutchi de l'asile qui fait
honneur à notre république est bien au
delà qui s'inscrit dans l'histoire de
france
avant la révolution même puisqu'il y
avait ces facilités de protéger les
opprimés et qui ont traversé tous les
régimes politiques qui font l'honneur un
autre qui font honneur à notre pays bien
si on veut protéger ce principe de
l'asile il faut très clairement veiller
à ce que les procédures ne soit pas
dévoyée pour qu'elle ne soit pas dévoyé
il faut envoyer un message clair
ceux qui sont déboutés de l'asile du
droit d'asile ce qu'ils ne deviennent
pas réfugiés doivent être éloignés vers
leur pays d'origine
et bien pour cela il ya une mesure très
simple c'est le placement en rétention
notamment de ceux qui viennent des pays
d'origine sûr c'est une de nos
propositions essentielles forte parce
qu'il n'y a aucune raison qu'on examine
pendant des mois des demandes d'asile de
ressortissants venant de pays où il n'y
a aucun problème aucune difficulté où il
n'ya pas de conflits armés où il n'y a
pas d'atteinte à la démocratie et il n'y
a de façon générale la nécessité pour
cela pour faciliter l'éloignement de
replacer la rétention administrative au
coeur des dispositifs d'éloignement on
aura beaucoup de mesures techniques qu
on défendra par amendement à l'assemblée
nationale mais il y en a une qui est
essentielle elle avait été enlevée par
le gouvernement socialiste
elle n'est pas réinstaurer par le
gouvernement aujourd'hui de monsieur
philippe et par monsieur collomb c'est
la rétention administrative
l'assignation à résidence n'a aucun
effet on dit à quelqu'un vous devez
quitter le territoire et on lui demande
gentiment de bien vouloir quitter le
territoire en lui assignant une
domiciliation qui est souvent fictives
et qui ne permet pas lorsqu on doit
procéder a l'obligation de quitter le
territoire français de mettre en
application cette mesure administrative
pour qu'elle soit appliquée il faut
qu'il y ait une assignation à résidence
de façon beaucoup plus systématique ces
mesures elle ne rétention administrative
ces mesures elles sont absentes du texte
donc pas de volonté très claire de
faciliter l'éloignement et une
augmentation de l'attractivité de notre
pays pour des flux migratoires
de plus en plus un contrôle et ce sont
deux motivations mais il y en a beaucoup
d'autres qui nous conduisent a rejeté en
l'état ce texte
oui mérite bien de parler de leur
travail
pierre-henri merci anne est également un
point qui est extrêmement important je
pense est une sorte de paradoxe qui
existe dans ce texte puisque on a d'un
côté un gouvernement qui désirent
réduire à six mois l'examen des demandes
d'asile et qui permet également de
travailler après six mois du dépôt de la
demande d'asile ce qui prouve bien qu'en
fait ils savent dès le début qu'ils ne
pourront pas respecter ce délai d'examen
des six mois et c'est donc un aveu de
faiblesse de pouvoir ouvrir ce droit du
travail à toute personne qui est présent
depuis plus de six mois puisque
normalement l'objectif est qu'il soit
renvoyé dans son pays
dans la majorité des cas ou alors
accueilli en france dans ses six mois
également je devais faire un point sur
la situation à calais puisque étant
député de calais et du calaisis je pense
que c'est important c'est un point nodal
de la situation aiguë du phénomène
migratoire en france et on voit bien que
ce texte en fait ne répond absolument
pas aux demandes des acteurs du terrain
les territoires en nous ce que nous
demandions et ça a été précisée dans les
propositions présentées par les
républicains c'est que chaque migrant
qui fait ou commet un crime ou délit
soient placés en rétention fut expulsé
on voit bien la situation la situation à
calais c'est qu'on a tous les jours une
centaine d' intrusion sur le port de
calais où sur le tunnel sous la manche
des détériorations de marchandises des
détériorations de camions val via
l'ouverture et des bâches des camions
est en réalité rien ne changera avec ce
nouveau texte est la situation actuelle
et restera la même
restera d'autant plus la même que le
sujet clé sur le calaisis c'est qu'on
nous avons des demandeurs des migrants
qui peuvent demander l'asile en très
grande majorité mais qui ne demande pas
et on voit bien que rien n'est prévu
pour ce cas cette zone grise qui est que
des migrants désirant ou pouvant
demander l'asile ne le font pas et c'est
en tout cas bien décevant puisque les
promesses qui avaient été faites par
emmanuel macron aussi bien lors de sa
venue à calais il ya trois semaines que
lors du sommet de sanders avec theresa
may quelques jours après n'ont
absolument pas été tenus et ne vont en
réalité rien changé à la situation
migratoire du calaisis au contraire
risque de l'empiré
avec l'ouverture de nouvelles filières
d'immigration illégale avec les mineurs
isolés en prenant en compte tous les
drames humains que ça peut avoir c'est à
dire que le développement de filières
migratoires il égalait de réseaux de
mafia qui vont prendre des jeunes
mineurs de 15 16 ans venant des pays du
sahel pour les envoyer mourir dans les
les routes de méditerranée va pour ceux
qui vont peu qu'ils vont passer créer
des points de fixation encore plus là où
ça existe déjà c'est à dire par exemple
a calé mais également à paris dans les
alpes-maritimes et dans tous les
endroits peu connaissons en france donc
c'est un texte qui est au delà de sa
présentation qui nous fait croire qu'il
peut être extrêmement dure en réalité
d'un texte qui est très laxiste il ne
faut pas se laisser berner par les
communication gouvernementale sur ce
sujet merci c'est vrai que des fois on
fait le procès aux républicains de faire
une obstruction systématique et bien
justement vous prouve que c'est le
contraire ce matin en conseil des
ministres le gouvernement a d évoquer ce
texte sur l'immigration
et avant même que le texte arrive sur le
bureau de l'assemblée ou du sénat je
sais pas dans quel on débattait de
présenter avant même qu'il arrive sur
donc dans nos assemblées bien
effectivement vous dit qu' un certain
nombre de points dans ce texte qui ne
nous conviennent pas et qui donc
justifieront soit le vote au sénat d'un
autre texte sur la base de celui qui
sera proposé soit effectivement les
discussions autour d'un amendement que
nous allons vous présenter vous aurez
observé je pense au travers des
explications qui ont été données par mes
collègues que ce texte n'est qu'un
ajustement procédural qui ne change
évidemment rien ni sur les flux d'entrée
sauf à les aggraver
ni sur les flux de sortie puisque vous
en connaissez les limites et ne dit fini
rien qu'en pour pas qu'on vingtaine
ration alors il y a simplement un point
sur lequel je voudrais revenir parce que
je le trouve
important même si d'autres points sont
importants c'est le cas de ceux qui
connaissent qui commettent des crimes ou
des délits et qui sont dans le flux
d'immigration ou de demande d'asile
il est évident car dès lors qu'on a
commis un crime ou un délit dans le pays
d'où l'on vient ou dans notre pays on
peut effectivement pas donné suite à la
demande d'asile ça c'est me paraît tout
à fait limpide
sauf qu'il faut se donner les moyens de
pouvoir les expulser
et là il n'y a rien de tangible puisque
nos capacités sont insuffisantes
insuffisante au niveau de la rétention
ça a été exprimée par mes collègues
puisque les places ne sont pas en
adéquation avec les flux et d'autre part
sur les moyens donnés les moyens humains
matériels données aux forces de sécurité
pour qu'effectivement on puisse
raccompagner à la frontière expulser
ceux qui doivent l'être
voilà ces points là sur lesquelles je
souhaite insister car je trouve qu'il y
a de grandes faiblesses actuellement
mais il y en aura encore demain après
l'adoption du texte du gouvernement
oui merci je voulais insister sur
quelques aspects et notamment dans et
déjà vous dire que tout au long des
débats parlementaires tant commission
des lois conscience publique nous allons
essayé de braquer quelques projecteurs
sur la situation de l'asile
d'immigration dans les grands pays
européens qui nous entoure et essayé de
situer nos débats et nos travaux france
est dans une perspective européenne
parce qu'il peut sembler paradoxal à
l'heure où s'ébauche à la fois au sein
des institutions européennes
un travail sur un droit d'asile européen
et à l'heure où plusieurs de nos très
grands partenaires européens à commencer
par l'allemagne ont durci les règles en
matière de droit d'asile
particulièrement les règles en matière
de regroupement familial
il peut sembler paradoxal d'aller
dans d'autres directions vous le savez
ce sont des évolutions négatives toute
récente de l'allemagne en 2016 a discuté
et voté sous l'égide d'une majorité cdu
spd des règles durcissant le droit
d'asile les règles durcissant les
conditions du regroupement familial il
ya eu également l'introduction d'un
début de commencement de conditionnalité
pour se voir accorder les facilités de
visas on le sait l'un des défis auquel
tous les pays européens à faire face
notamment le nôtre lorsque il y a des
dossiers de demande d'asile qui sont
retoqués c'est que on obtient très très
difficilement les fameux laissez passer
consulaires qui sont les sésames
nécessaire pour effectivement pouvoir
renvoyer les déboutés du droit d'asile
dans les pays dont ils sont originaires
il ya des possibilités certains de nos
partenaires européens à commencer par
l'allemagne
on réfléchit à dix voies et moyens pour
soi entrer dans un dialogue diplomatique
francs pour obtenir véritablement
facilement et rapidement ces fameux
laissez passer consulaires soi même
trouvé à travers des accords bilatéraux
avec tel ou tel pays je pense par
exemple à un accord bilatéral entre
l'allemagne et l'albanie trouver les
voies et moyens pour ne plus être tenus
d'obtenir à tout prix c'est de laisser
passer consulaire albanais mais pouvoir
renvoyer les demandeurs d'asile de
nationalité albanaise donc débouté dans
leur pays d'origine sur base de papier
allemand tout s'assemble technique mais
ça fait partie de procédure et de choix
législatif et donc politiques qui ont
été faits par plusieurs de nos pays
voisins et dont nous aurions tort de ne
pas tenir compte encore une fois il
serait extraordinairement paradoxal et
contradictoire que d'avoir dans notre
propre dispositif législatif cet
élargissement du regroupement familial
notamment ça a été dit par plusieurs
d'entre nous pour les mineurs réfugiés
et de ne pas voir ce qui a commencé à
être mises en oeuvre et qui marche dans
les autres pays européens qui nous
entoure merci constance voilà mesdames
et messieurs des questions très bien bas
nous vous remercions